una cifra sin precedentes de pérdidas
humanas dejan las lluvias torrenciales e
inundaciones repentinas en india y nepal
aunque los expertos dieron por
finalizada la época del monzón
generalmente dura de junio a septiembre
los desbordamientos y deslizamientos de
tierra han generado inesperadamente
pérdidas de todo tipo para cientos de
personas para darnos algo digo yo que
apremian la vega naval y el refrigerador
fue destruido el enfriador del aire
también fue arrastrado también perdimos
algo de efectivo se perdieron algunos
alimentos incluidos al menos 30
kilogramos de arroz y trigo todo fue
arrastrado vamos a bragas valen casas
que se inundaron deja miles de familias
desplazadas sin mencionar las pérdidas
económicas en el sector de la ganadería
y la agricultura
en la vecina india aunque la lluvia cesó
los deslizamientos de tierra han
provocado derrumbes cierres de
carreteras y cortes de energía ya pensar
que la mayoría de las carreteras se han
despejado excepto tres de ellas también
comenzamos a enviar material de ayuda a
los hogares donde lo necesitan
y
permanecer aquí es muy difícil las
autoridades deberían tomar nota de los
daños y ayudar a recuperarnos
mientras las labores de búsqueda y
rescate continúan en ambos países las
autoridades meteorológicas advierten de
nuevas precipitaciones en varias zonas